dans ce contexte extrêmement dangereux
vous l'avez vu deux français viennent de
disparaître il s'agit d'un chercheur du
centre d'études du moyen-orient arrivée
à l'aéroport de beyrouth mercredi après
midi en compagnie d'un journaliste de
l'événement du jeudi jean paul kauffmann
aussitôt débarqué les deux hommes ont
pris en voiture la route vers le centre
ville la suite c'est le rédacteur en
chef du magazine l'événement du jeudi
albert du roy qui la raconte à daniel
leconte
jean paul kauffmann donc l'envoyé
spécial de l'événement et michel saura
qui est un chercheur du cnrs qui connaît
très bien le liban ont pris ensemble à
l'aéroport de beyrouth à taxi un témoin
qui a donné son témoignage un journal
libanais les a vus arrêter un barrage à
hauteur des camps de sabra et chatila
qui sont l'objet actuellement de combat
entre chiites et palestiniens depuis on
n'a plus aucune nouvelle à partir de ce
moment là commencent les hypothèses
alors actuellement il ya deux hypothèses
qui sont formulées et par le quai
d'orsay et donc par nous première
hypothèse est pris dans les combats ils
se sont cachés et ils ne peuvent pas
puis trois jours je vais donner de leurs
nouvelles deuxième hypothèse ils ont été
enlevés par un mouvement par un
groupuscule
tout à fait indéterminée puisque aucune
revendication n'a été formulée
l'ambassade de france à beyrouth après
contact avec les principaux mouvements
de diverses obédiences tous ont démenti
avoir procédé à l'enlèvement tous l'ont
condamné mais il ya tellement de groupes
incontrôlés à beyrouth actuellement que
tout est possible le problème c'est que
actuellement et le gouvernement français
et nous mêmes on ne sait pas très bien
ce qu'on peut faire dans la mesure où la
situation à beyrouth et d'une confusion
extrême on ne sait même pas à qui
s'adresser pour essayer d'avoir des
nouvelles